they say time is money
but what does one really have to do with
the other meet Sheila she just got her
first big bonus Sheila knows exactly
what she wants to do with that money
she's had her eye on a nice convertible
for a while now yes Sheila that's a nice
car
Oh looks like Sheila is a little short
but wait she has an idea Sheila is a
smart cookie she knows that if she
deposits the money for a year instead of
buying the car today she will earn
interest then she'll be able to afford
the car
Sheila knows that the value of her
deposit one year from now will equal the
money deposited today plus the interest
earned we call Sheila's money deposited
today the present value of money and the
value of Sheila's deposit next year is
the future value of money what connects
one to the other the interest rate also
known as the time value of money now
with a little bit of rearranging we can
figure out the future value of Sheila's
money with this equation so in a year
the future value will be eleven thousand
dollars well it's been a year and
there's Sheila with enough money to buy
the car Sheila really understands the
future value of money now I just hope
she understands the speed limit now meet
Timmy he's also gotten his bonus the
money seems to be burning a hole in his
pocket yes Timmy that's a nice car that
will surely impress people Oh looks like
you're a little short maybe you can
follow Sheila's example you see Timmy
just like Sheila after the first year
you'll have eleven thousand dollars but
Timmy
that is still not enough to buy that
fancy car why don't you leave the money
deposited for another year let's see how
your deposit would be doing in two years
with a little bit of rearranging it
becomes the value of your money next
year times 1 plus the interest rate we
can then convert the future value one
year from now to the present value times
1 plus the interest rate we can even
simplify this further by just squaring
the value of 1 plus the interest rate
sorry Timmy you'll have more money after
two years but you still can't afford the
car I don't know how many more years
you'll have to wait but I can tell you
one way we can figure it out do you see
that little number two in the equation
any number that you put in there is the
number of years that you are waiting
also know as the period sure Timmy we
can see how much you'll have in five
years let's connect future value and
present value across five years let's
watch the period increase from two to
five after five years you'll have
sixteen thousand one hundred five
dollars and ten cents sorry Timmy you
have to wait a little longer ten years
yeah let's see if you'll be able to buy
the car then not quite well Timmy it
looks like you'll need 26 years to
afford this car you should ask Sheila
for a ride to the beach maybe a bicycle
will suit you better
I hear the bus is pretty cheap
you